at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking when I ask you a personal
question no it was soon I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal ZOA
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for years I love
audiobooks and I have to to recommend
right off the bat number one is pressed
my favorite audio book of all time and
that is the graveyard book by neil
gaiman the only audio book I've wanted
to immediately listen to a second time
as soon as I finished it's amazing you
will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding Bhairav pots which
had a huge impact on my life and form
the basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible com forward slash Tim and you
can choose one of those two books the
graveyard book vagabonding or more than
180,000 audio programs so that could be
a book that could be a magazine that
could be a newspaper could be a class
it's that easy go to audible.com forward
slash Tim that's audible com forward
slash Tim and grab a book enjoy this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
when your business needs a logo website
business card thumbnail or any other
design I recommend checking out
99designs I use them myself I've used
them for many years I use them to create
book cover prototypes for the 4-hour
body which went on to becoming number
one New York Times best seller I've also
used them for banner ads illustrations
and much more with 99designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and
designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs.com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free nine million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99
designs.com forward slash Tim
Fosse's loss gutentag this is tim
ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job to deconstruct world-class
performers whether they are from the
world of entertainment chess sports or
otherwise this episode is a special
double-header it features one interview
and one performance which is a new thing
first up is cascade kask a de you can
say hello to him at cascade on most of
social he is widely considered one of
the founding fathers of progressive
house music he's been voted America's
best DJ twice by DJ times headlined
coachella four times and has been
nominated for Grammys five times next up
you'll hear saku Andrews that's SE KO u
andrews so at say cout Andrews across
social and he is the most impressive
poetic voice I've ever heard I first saw
him perform at Ted where he blew my mind
and so I approached him afterwards he is
a school teacher turned two-time
National Poetry Slam champion he's
presented privately for Barack Obama
bono Oprah Winfrey the list goes on and
on each one of these takes a few minutes
to get warmed up so be patient I know
it's not a specialty for those in the
digital world but there are gems in both
of them among other things cascade
covers his first breaks making his own
luck formative music and influences if
his music were or I should say rather
electronic or dance music were a wine
tasting what would he recommend the
varietals be who should we listen to
what were his biggest albums in the
early days and we dig into his
note-taking process as you may know i'm
a nerd that kind of thing i want to know
the origins of his biggest hits how did
they come to be what was the time span
between the first note taking and them
going live etc we talk about all of that
seiko will inspire you to be inspired by
your story so if you want to change your
narrative your internal dialogue to be
more successful this is a good talk to
listen to if you want to get back on the
horse or have an effective pep talk in
your back pocket this might be the
recording you listen to over and over
again now you should be patient i'm
going to mention this again because
there's a lot of practical philosophy
embedded in between the
so you have to listen to it all you have
to listen carefully and these are very
contrasting i should say different
rather personalities and very different
performances and so i hope that you
enjoy both of them you can certainly
skip around and i'll mention just a
couple of notes these were both recorded
at a live event in Los Angeles and that
sold out in 30 minutes based on an email
that I sent out to my my newsletter
subscribers if you're not on the
newsletter it's free and you get lots of
exclusives and cool stuff like 500
friday which has more than a sixty
percent open rate across the board for
people who know what that is that's
unheard of and you can sign up try it
out for a week or two at 4-hour workweek
calm forward slash friday so all spelled
out four hour workweek calm forward
slash friday now since it was a live
event there were a couple of audio
glitches early on and in the case of
cascade we had a mic failure and i ended
up pulling out my lavalier mic you know
the clip-on mic that was threaded down
my shirt pulling it out and handing that
back and forth for a bit so you might
hear a couple of missteps here and there
but what you missed was a little bit of
background he was raised mormon he was
born in chicago he went to Utah for
college and where he grew up was where
they filmed Ferris Bueller's Day Off
among other things so without further
ado please enjoy this episode with
cascade and sake who enters when did you
have your first what you would consider
your first break or mentor and music
let's see when I moved to San Francisco
I reached out to own records there were
a small boutique label based right in
the city there South of Market area and
really they were the only people I knew
in San Francisco because I had some
demos and I was mailing music to people
and that wasn't going so well but they'd
showed a little interest and I moved
there luckily they hired me for like the
play thing is is like my wife and I we
couldn't even make rent for what we were
I mean she supported me for many years
she was working for Levi Strauss at the
headquarters there and it was great I
was like yeah you get a good job i'm
gonna do music we'll see how that turns
out I'm awesome who you married listen
well you know if that were a stock that
she had bought she's pretty happy I'm
imagining everything worked out the when
did you realize that this is something
you could do to support yourself full
time or even think that was boss was
like the mid-2000s so 10 years ago you
know 10 11 years ago but people are like
when do you really decide you're going
to do music and I was one of those
people that never wanted to admit that
that would I was that's what I was doing
I kept telling my she's like well what
are you doing what do you know what your
plan and she was pretty organized and
very driven and um I think I didn't want
to like say that because I didn't want
to be a failure I didn't want to have
like no I'm gonna be a musician I'm
gonna write music I wanted my whole
thing was there was like no this is a
cool hobby I'm doing it these guys hired
me I'll go there I'll work for what
we'll see what happens let's just listen
we'll see what happens that was always
my thing so what did you at the time
when people would ask you because I know
people do this in San Francisco as well
as many other cities be like so so what
do you do how do you answer that at the
time music would you San Francisco
people think that's cool there's enough
our community there and people at school
what do you know how are you living like
on my wife she
I just got a good job I so is it I had
in the course of doing research for this
read that when you when you went from
Chicago to Utah just I know we're
jumping around chronologically that that
is when you started sort of producing or
creating your own music because there
wasn't much of a scene if it is that
accurate this is a great this is a great
point so what happened is is I'm like
okay I got into University of Utah for
Mormons out there nam one is out there
it's like for me I grew up as a kid in
Chicago there wasn't very many more of
my kids so I thought I'll go to school
in Utah meet other Mormon people see
what they're about you know I was fun
with all these Jewish kids groan Chicago
is like all my friends are Jewish up
like anyway so I went to Utah and um
that was great but I growing up going to
nightclubs all through high school teen
clubs were a big deal in Chicago and
that's how I got introduced in the house
music was very much a part of my life I
was collecting records you know as a
hobby I was a DJ um so when I got there
I'm like was this music you guys this is
terrible you know like I've got crates
of Records when I you come with my house
I got some speakers so you know I
started throwing my own parties and I
really had to get involved that was
definitely a point where I was like wow
if I'm gonna be a part of the scene or
or make music I'm gonna have to be
active instead of just like some passive
guy because in Chicago I just be the guy
that went out and collected records and
occasionally played at friends house
party but when I got to you I was like
if I want to do this and we have to make
my own thing which is good because it
inspired me to get involved and really
get motivated how did you loud enough
now uh how did you get your first gear
or equipment of course that's evolved a
lot since but so I hit a local club
owner up in Utah and I was like I got
crates of Records and what's your worst
night that you have what's the slowest
night when he's like monday i'm not even
open i'm like dude let me come down a
monday night and this is a bar that had
opened in the 40s and had all its
original decor is called Club
Manhattan's amazing place in the
basement anyway the owners like you know
I'll give you a cut of the door you have
your friends come in whatever invite
some people will see what happens anyway
that turned out the night was a smash I
mean I did it for five years and I ended
up doing two nights a week it was Monday
and then when I took on a Thursday and
things worked almost instantly and I
quit my you know I was working at a
clothing store you know trying to
support myself going to school and I
quit like after the first week I was
like I'm done with dad I'm just going to
do this DJ this is great and I can make
some cash and I can pay for school so
it's started clicking and then when I
was making enough money I started by my
first video equipment and I slowly
started producing songs and getting into
that and learning my way around the
studio and like wow does a sampler work
how does a digital audio workstation how
does this all work and just
understanding that which was great
because it's like I was going to school
I thought I was really busy at the time
but I realize now that like I had a lot
of free time I'm so busy I'm gonna see
her for 10 hours and work on this song
you know like um anyway so I had a lot
of time to kind of just learn my craft
so it's a good time for me um and then
when I moved to San Francisco that
definitely took it up a notch i worked
from records for a couple years and it
was good because I was I knew how to
make the music but I didn't understand
anything about the business I wasn't
really interested in business I was like
I just want to make music I want all
this other stuff but it forced me to
learn some things about the business
which was cool because I could see like
oh you can't just like hang out in your
room and make tracks you got to get out
and promote them and be a part of the
scene and get out there and people want
to know who you are as an artist who's
writing these songs and yeah so I kind
of slowly started building up from there
in san francisco and i'm sure you get
approached a lot with people who are
hoping to create their own electronic
music or maybe they already are if one
of those people were to ask you how to
create of a self-directed mba they're
like look i have the time i have a
little bit of resources what skills
should I learn like what's that what
does the curriculum look like in terms
of
setting the stage for being a successful
musician in that category I'm this genre
I always tell people that are getting
started out I mean now there are schools
for this and you can go you know
18-month things to a 12-month program so
it's a lot easier to learn the craft now
than it was back then back then I was
buying like these $25 magazines from the
UK electronic musician I'm like what now
$25 like I'm broke man anyway they had a
lot of good tutorials so it's a very
different back then now it's a little
more accessible but I always tell people
i mean like what's your passion what do
you truly love about this music is do
you want to write do you want to produce
are you a songwriter find out what you
do best and put all your time and energy
into that like are really good at just
djing is that we do you're a selector is
that what you do you can pull good
tracks you have a good ear so some
people that do that and do that really
well then go out and figure out how to
maximize that figure out what is that
you do best and really run with it like
maybe you and you got to be honest to
yourself it's like one of those things
that it might take a year or two to
discover you're out in the mix you're
going to clubs you're trying to get gigs
or whatever it is but I think it's just
kind of good to sit back and like check
the climate like what am i doing well in
order people drawn to me like what's
working here and then just do that as
much as you can how did you and feel
free to to verify this also again just
in the course of an research but when
did you realize that you're very good at
more melodic music as opposed to beats
or rhythmic based and I would love you
for even to just differentiate those
four people much of dance music is very
rhythmic my dad was like why is the kick
drum so damn loud and I'm like best
dance music there so it's very many
people see this repetitive whatever that
that's kind of the old dance music
because it was pretty simplistic we
didn't have the technology wasn't as
sophisticated as now and when i moved to
san francisco in two thousand that was
kind of like the beginnings of more
melodic electronic music
songwriting was getting involved and
there are a couple acts there's one band
locally called solstice they were great
extremely talented their band but it was
more electronic sounding and I remember
sitting at the label they were signed to
ohm I'm like because I'd been on all
this stuff that was very sample heavy
and rhythmic kind of the trend at the
time like but I wasn't making any
Headroom i was i was there was no
headway i was just kind of like because
i was like every dude out there you know
my demo sounded just like everybody
else's anyway as I kind of sat in the
office and SAT back and was like
thinking what would work and how could I
make myself different I thought you know
there's not that much melodic stuff out
there what if I focused more on the song
and I had been in the scene quite a long
time even at that point in my career
that I'd seen like this goes in cycles
and people get into different styles and
one production style progressive house
is cool today techno school tomorrow
drum and bass is cool next week it moves
really quick in the underground so I was
like man if I focused more on songs and
songwriting that could be my thing that
could be my space and there's not very
many people doing it so I could make my
own name that way and it would be more
evergreen I guess in that respect I
didn't have more durability yeah and
then I mean that was just I didn't think
of that at the time but that's kind of
what happened naturally and it all kind
of coincided with me meeting some people
that were really good song writers that
were like man you're talented in the
studio but dude that's just one part of
it making the music a song that's an
instrumental that's half a song is half
an idea and I was like what yeah oh my
gosh this is great I thought that was a
song that's a song you know and they're
like now this is it son so I met and
hung out with some people had some
different ideas are there any particular
song writers who had a large influence
on your that you look up to um
I mean I go with like classics like
staying or the morrissey you know I grew
up in the 80s so like a new way it was a
big deal for me Robert Smith the cure I
love this guy's and brilliant songwriter
so that stuff I was always drawn to but
you know as I worked with more
songwriters like okay I can develop this
is a graft I fancy myself a bit of a
writer writing songs is different but
it's still kind of just getting your
idea on a little short three minute
piece so kind of marrying the two things
that I was doing but then that that's
when everything kind of changed for in
my career things really as I started
producing that kind of music people
notice me and I started touring quickly
after that I mean 2003 is really when
things started to move I think that year
I did like 70 or 80 shows and I was like
this is insane and that's when I was
like what I sign up for but you're never
here you know what is your record for
consecutive shows or consecutive days
with shows um I don't know I've never
counted that that's really that's a
really good question i know i've done
like 12 or 14 I mean it's not uncommon
for me to do 23 24 25 shows in a month
in the summer summer is extremely busy I
mean it's always somewhere somewhere so
it's busy all the time but i always take
our winter I always kind of slow down a
little bit how do you what what type of
rituals or self-care do you have to keep
from getting extremely sick during that
type of just onslaught in a month we are
constantly performing during particular
diet performance part of its not hard
for me because I feel very natural I
mean I've been doing this for over 20
years so for me I feel very at home on
stage and doing in my space and I feel
like that just naturally keeps things
out it's very aerobic you know it's like
a workout really I walk upstage of lost
five pounds I'm drenched in sweat so I
think that part of it is actually quite
healthy and then just like eating and
living clean really why I'm on the road
you know we're traveling from place to
place it's like we travel during the day
and we sleep we sleep on the planes and
we perform at night when i say we i
travel with a small clique of guys that
that help me execute the shows although
than the artists i have a tour manager
photographer videographer a lighting guy
a visual guy sometimes the sound guy it
depends on the size of the show but it
can be anywhere from five people up to
25 people but i think that kind of
philosophy has just kind of worked its
way down to to everybody i work with
that and what i can i travel with my
family I'm married and I have three
children so I'm always trying to figure
out okay how kind of make this work you
know putting the stones in the in the
bucket like okay what's really important
here and how can I can fill the bucket
with the things that are really
important to me how would you describe
your parenting style I'm sorry your
parenting style how would you describe
your parent or how do you think of
parenting my style of parenting wow if
you're definitely never been a set um oh
man i wish naomi was here my my wife
she's she's uh she's amazing cuz listen
she gambled on me took a she had no idea
where this was heading or where it was
going and she's really been there to
take care of the family and been like my
biggest fan and champion in my corner
from day one and without your honestly
none of it would be possible because it
is fully a team effort on every front
and my business she was my business
management for ten years and she's been
the primary parent and the
disciplinarian in our home because she's
there and she has to be because i'm not
there as often as she is so that's
extremely important to note that because
that's how it's worked in my home me I'm
kind of she always gets mad when I'm
angry at the kids she's like no no I
have to be the anger on you have to be
like the soft guy that gives them
everything
I'm totally cool i could do that i could
do that like ice cream it's Monday no
it's usually monday tues they're
typically my weekend because I come home
on you know sunday or monday from
traveling all weekend and then I've got
Monday Tuesday a window to kind of hang
out with the family you know in their
back at school so I'm always wanted to
do like let's go to a movie on Monday
night yeah no yeah uh I am I have a
constant note taker and I watched an
interview of yours where you talked
about writing down ideas for songs in a
notebook do you still take a lot a lot
of notes have a notebook just like that
at home filled with gibberish and
highlights and little things um yes I
think that interview was about I early
on in my career I got pulled over
stopped in London after I had been on
like a four sho binge sure I showed up
at the border and I look to probably
completely crack that I hadn't slept in
days and they pulled me over cuz I
didn't have the right permits or the
right work credentials to get in there
and I sat in this room for 12 hours and
I hadn't eaten I don't know I was a very
down moment for me but they had taken
apart this notebook and photocopy to
everything I mean I you know this thing
was almost full when I got there but I
keep one of these with me and I thought
they thought it was some like drug log
the web traffic of my drop so they
photocopied everything it like what does
this mean I'm like that that says that
do my laundry when i get home what he's
talking about it's not code I need to do
my laundry there's no code there man um
eventually they let me off and
everything turns out okay except I was
escorted back on the plane the next day
with a cop all the way that was funny um
another time uh but yeah I mean this is
how I organize my life I have a lot of
ideas and thoughts all the time and I
just continued to write things down and
look over that and you know perfect that
process do you have a particular routine
for reviewing the notes or is it more of
a journaling exercise we just put it
down you don't go back and review it um
for me it's in the morning kind of what
I
first sit down I look at what i was
trying to accomplish the day before and
what's kind of overlapping and what
didn't happen and kind of carries over
into that next day and then I looked
throughout the week and then I look at
any potential song ideas or any notes
that I have or ideas that could lead to
a song what do those look like I mean
I'm assuming do your laundry isn't isn't
one of them but like what what is the
what form does it take is just it could
be a single word could it be um I please
I always like to use the example I wrote
a song called 4am and it's one of my
more popular ones in my catalog thank
you i'll tell the story because it's i
was playing at kinking not too far down
the street I was in from San Francisco
and when I play kinking there was like a
640 a.m. flight so I'd play all night
and then I could get french toast across
the street and I take my luggage eat the
french toast and then get in the cab and
catch the flight get home get home on
Sunday morning to see my family anyway
um I was sitting there for him and I was
a just one of those massive nights in my
career where I kind of hit a moment
where I was like this is really gonna
work I have a few of these moments along
my career but that was one of them was
like what an incredible night I mean
looking back was a very small club it
holds like four or five hundred people
maybe um but it was like lying around
the block and I just knew things were
clicking so I was on this I was on a
high I was just floating and it was four
in the morning when I walked into the
french toast place and I got my luggage
then I opened up my bag and I'm like I
have to write a song about 4am and
sleepless gliding and these words
started coming to me it was just like a
couple phrases and talk about 4am eating
french toast and gliding on the streets
without any sleep and that became the
first verse and then it just blossomed
into an idea I think it's kind of like
looking back at my notes when I'm in the
studio and thinking like is this is this
something that anyone could relate to
you know and then making a song out of
it really how long did it take from that
initial note-taking to being out in the
world as a song would you say I think
about that album was about six months
later so sitting around circled in that
book you know I'd go back to it like
that's a cool idea memorized in there I
was like I should develop this more and
sit on write a song about that moment do
you collect anything or a header records
records vinyl lots and lots of vinyl
Ethan's antacids record okay any
particular genre it's all I mean it's
mostly particularly it's like dance
music house music or the house music
stuff that I started when I collecting
when I was a kid then when I had a
little bit more money I started buying
like old new wave records old punk
record it's a some hip hop you know just
stuff that interested me bands that were
seminal to me personally so for dance
music if people here like myself I'm
naive of the entire genre and I really I
can enjoy dancers depended on the first
thing about it if I wanted to do the
equivalent of a wine tasting with dance
music it's like try like oh yeah I think
that's below i'm not sure and try a few
different options to educate myself but
there any particular artists or albums
that you would suggest people start with
um among many of course is going to pick
favorites I guess I am that's kind of an
old school way of thinking I think if
you're into electronic music now I'd
flip open Spotify and go listen to
there's like a million playlist that i
run cascade radio and i add four or five
tracks on there every every week that
I'm like oh this is stuff that I'm
feeling and it's predominantly
electronic music I wouldn't say dance
music because there's a lot of left
field stuff in there but yeah seminal
records I mean Daft Punk homework to me
is still kind of like one of the top
records that defined our genre so or
discovery not as big a fan as discovery
that's a very controversial thing to say
but I'm a homework guy because I don't
know that I hit me at the right time
time in my life that's a big one any
craft work
um I don't know it's lot of stuff out
there but I think I think going to
Spotify and hitting it because what's
interesting about electronic music I
think one at one point it was a genre
and it was a very specific it kind of
surrounded a culture but now really and
truly this is pretty much how most the
music's made I mean everybody works on a
computer on a laptop even with the
recording rock and roll and it's all
augmented in processed and it's all
electronic driven for better or for
worse and that's another conversation I
could argue both sides I see the
downsides in that but really the way we
were thinking 25 30 years ago working
with drum machines and sampling and 0
recording on a multitrack that's in a
computer this is just how everyone
operates today I mean that's what pop
music is I mean listen turn on the radio
to me it's all dance music I'm like God
we were doing that 10 years ago this is
cool as a modern take on what was
happening a long time ago so I know what
you have we have we have a heart out I'm
really happy that you're able to make it
we have a couple of minutes so I'm going
to ask a couple of the normal questions
that i tend to when wrapping up what
book or books have you gifted most to
other people if any um I knew you're
gonna ask this I thought about I'm like
man I don't give any books away um but i
just recently give lights out to a
friend so i'm going to select it's the
most recent thing I red lights out yeah
and it's about cyber terrorism and how
they gonna cut the power off and we're
gonna be screwed um it was a really
interesting read and scared the crap if
you had to pick an underappreciated
festival what would you pick that
a great question and I'm stalling to how
man there's so many quills data if I
wasn't here in California to Coachella
occurs to me that still is the best
festival in the entire world and I've
played literally hundreds if not
thousands of festivals but I don't know
they got a lot of cool stuff going on in
New York electric zoo New York's
actually really cool it's on Randall's
Island and you're looking at the skyline
while you're playing is pretty cool but
there's a handful those me that's when
i'd have to think then like go through
my dial we go through my diary be like
where I'd been recently we do around
here sometime uh when you think it word
successful it was the first person who
comes to mind and why my wife and she's
she's the rock and she's who I look to
all the time it seems like she kind of
efforts Italy effortlessly glides
between family life and supporting me
and making everything work so yeah she's
she's success she's the model of success
to me
if you had one billboard anywhere you
put anything on it where would you put
on it uh let's see probably Times Square
just cuz that's for most people to see
it I don't know I'd probably throw in my
brands up there redo or something or
cascade I don't know in a big picture of
me like I'm coming to get you do you
have any any mottos or quotes or
anything that you say to yourself when
you're getting ready to perform that you
could put on the Billboard now but one
of the quotes it always comes back to me
in my career and some I always think
back to every time I left the house my
dad would always say remember who you
are I'm always like man that's now that
I'm a father this is a very profound
thing to me at the time I was like my
dad hotel you're so weird like I forget
who I am we see now I'm like gosh it I
was gonna see smart you know that
basically answers the next question so i
think we'll we'll wrap up with just
asking you where people can find more
about you your work your music whether
it's anywhere online early yeah i don't
know i'm on twitter instagram while the
social networks cascade music com come
and check me out I appreciate the time
you guys cascade with UK at cascade KSK
a de yeah yeah I want me an Instagram
you get some pretty crazy photos
Sumner's sure we would thank you so much
I really appreciate the time
anybody up taking a soul selfie anybody
I know you gonna taste selfies but have
you taken a soul selfie y'all don't know
nothing about this I'm a hippie I'm put
your long i'll put y'all on the soul
selfie it's the way that you can remind
yourself instantly that you a mighty
enough that you are beautiful enough
that you are powerful enough and strong
enough to get through anything and I
want y'all to do with me right now
everybody stand up real quick stand up
stand up stand up stand up stand up what
do i do I gotta do put one hand in the
air turn it around make a little claw
like you holding a hand mirror pinned it
off your charm lean into it and when you
see how powerful and beauty and mighty
you are you got to say the words I am Oh
so let's say we ready 123 I am Oh hold
on hold on hold on I don't believe you
hit it again I am you're damn right you
all sit down your power sit down your
power damn right you are that's how you
get through those days right one of
those days like I'm having right now you
know with my drive crashes right when my
self-worth stalls by the side of the
road my ambitions check engine light
comes on mid hustle and I find myself at
my bathroom mirror finger to glass
scratching the word can't into the heart
and steam but as I stare at my mercury
reflection with these broken down eyes
my reflection sees its reflection in me
from the other side and thinks itself oh
I don't know what he thinks he sees but
he must not be looking at me because I
am
so don't be wasting my tears I am more
than enough to get through this and I
got a scrapbook full of I can't do it to
prove it for I maintain a level of our
summit II and everything I do so my all
summation is not speculation but
irrefutable truth in fact the Census
Bureau just released a report that two
out of every three people are awesome
huh and if that is true then out of you
and you and I question we must now ask
ourselves is which one of you two is the
one that sucks because I am like finding
money in dirty laundry awesome Oh like
parking at that one meter that's broken
awesome like like that perfect person at
that perfect time saying that perfect
thing awesome like making a living doing
what you live for like somewhere rocking
out in New York City is a dude whose
resume actually reads national air
guitar champion somewhere in the Ukraine
is a woman who boasts a trophy for
national sand art champion here before
you in Los Angeles is a dude who has
earned the title National Poetry Slam
champion and and thank you thank you I
appreciate that because to most of the
working world all three of those titles
are equally freaking ridiculous but but
the most awesome five people on the
planet are we who embrace our
ridiculousness we live what we love and
we love incorrigibly which is why I
sleep quite well but I go to bed
horribly anybody else always hopped up
on a triple shot of purpose juggling my
dreams like 13 flaming swords and
chasing my aspirations through the
graveyard shift so that the world can
awake to my awesomeness
sniffs look it up and I'll admit I'll
admit I used to think that awesome was a
word for you know surfers and state
borders you know uh smokers and Valley
Girls but I was like totally mistaken
awesome is gangsta awesome is stupid
fresh awesome is the new crunk and the
new cool beans a new bomb diggity and
the newbies needs my new mantra that
helps me breathe into all that i believe
and see that within me is all the might
I'll ever need because there are those
days when I'm pushed to the edge we're
still waters meet earth and I fall to my
knees to look upon the water surface but
as I stare at my murky reflection with
these broken down eyes God sees his
reflection in me from the other side and
thinks to herself ah I don't know what
he thinks he sees but he must not be
looking at me because I am I like the
science of miracles and the mathematics
of purpose awesome like how the mind the
mind can always calculate the what of
who and the wind of where but the soul
must solve for y awesome like the
thought of God and logic having faith
that we will figure ourselves out
awesome like how the moment I truly
discovered the great I am is the same
moment I discovered how truly great I am
and I am not perfect but I'm perfect
like I am I'm not beautiful like I used
to be I'm beautiful like I am like the
star where her breasts once was like
survival where a death once was like the
better wear a best once was every gray
hair a trophy every wrinkle fold a story
every pound of fact a challenge
reminding me that there is always
something to pursue and always something
to celebrate that is why I never smile
for no reason that is a concept I don't
believe in do join never without a
reason to show off your teeth a bit let
me see let me see their baby there you
go huh spread out your cheeks a bit let
your gums breathe a bit if you can learn
to reach deeper it's you can take
yourself a piece of bliss and make
yourself a feast of it like when you go
buy a smoothie and they fill it to full
right making more than your cup can hold
but instead of letting they just spill
all over what I do what I do they give
you a little extra cup and you feel like
you just want a smoothie lottery over
here awesome like that perfect day what
was yours that perfect day right one of
mine was like the first time to stretch
limo driver pulled up to the first the
five-star hotel to transport me to my
first class flight after my sold-out
show and curiously peering at me through
the rearview mirror he asked what do you
do for a living and with a pocket full
of sand and an air guitar in my hand I
replied I am a full-time toys now roll
up the damn divide
okay I didn't actually say you roll up
the damn divider but it would have been
awesome or if I had right would have
been but you know what a a next time
uh-huh and you better believe there will
be no shortage of next times but that's
the thing before you can believe it I
gotta believe it I gotta believe there
will be no shortage of next time that's
why this thing that I'm doing tonight is
not just pretty words not poetry for
poetry sake this is survival for me this
is survival for us I mean this you know
this is how we get through we have to
have instant ways to access our power
and our purpose and our passion our
truth to take to get through those days
and to do this thing we do this this
entrepreneurial innovation you know me
against the world instigation against
all odds death to all the haters think
we don't can maybe not just to all the
haters that's that's negative will stay
positive like like you know stub feet
and paper cuts and warts to all the
haters thing that we do right and it
ain't easy I know that I know that
nobody knows that more than me it's why
I'm gonna give you a powerful take away
tonight okay I don't care what is set on
this stage this will be the most
powerful thing that you leave here with
to help you get through your challenging
days of crafting your successful life
and all you have to do is repeat after
me right now at least I'm not trying to
build a successful life from poetry I
got no sympathy for y'all please
whatever is it hard for you what are you
in tech industry your billion dollar
industries I built my business off a
dead art form you hated in high school
please djs and state borders got it
easier than poets you know people look
when I used to introduce myself as a
full-time poet people used to look at me
like i said hi my name is segun I'm a
full-time mermaid nicely
all right they don't they don't get it
but that's alright that's alright
because with every moment of confusion
within someone else it was an
opportunity for clarity of purpose
within myself right I had to believe
that and I did I believe that I could
create a new user experience for the art
form of spoken word that could affect
the masses I believe that I could
dissolve the line between business
speaker and performance artists right
and create a new experience that has
enhanced both and so against all the
advice of everyone saying forget poetry
instead I embraced my ridiculousness and
I created a new style of speaking called
poetic voice that just blends
inspirational speaking with spoken word
poetry to create an experience that
allows me to go out and inspire people
in and help them tell their story and
show them the best version of themselves
right and to do that too awesome find my
life I had to be okay I had to be fine
with people not getting it the first
time so that I could believe in myself
long enough to create no shortage of
next times next times and now you don't
have to guess just check my specs I'm no
longer afraid to double down cuz I
tricked the deck I've already seen my
future so I'm unfit to bet that's why
whenever failure challenges me to
Russian roulette I rock a waterproof
poker face impervious to sweat cuz I
don't gamble with my life I count the
cards so my success is mathematics so
long as my dealer is God I can always
even my odds even on the days I can't
get over it I go through it to this
behind me on the days I can't levy the
waves I just learned to surf tsunamis on
the days I can't slay the Beast of
despair with my mighty sword of
confidence and I can I can still took a
razor blade beneath my tongue and
papercut despair one positive
affirmation at a time and when I
returned home from the wild rumpus
my awesome fest always vacuum with a
smile as I clean up my awesomeness for
there there are bits of mountaintop
buried in the grooves of the soles of my
shoes every footprint tracked on my
floor testifies to the heights off
climbed and proves I made it back home
each time so please remember embrace
your ridiculousness please go out there
and vacuum with a smile please remember
your awesome nation asst and be the
little extra cup for somebody else
because I find that on those days when
my weary soul can't seem to do another
single thing when the 24-hour threatens
to pop my days sings when the cup of my
ambitions begins to run us over in the
springs that perfect person at that
perfect time says that perfect thing and
I am handed an awesome little extra cup
by my my homie who shows up at my door
with a bottle of don julio for dirty
jokes and a scrapbook full of we don't
laugh about this later a little extra
cup by my lover sipping espresso at
midnight in a fireproof suit who takes
over the juggling of my flaming swords
and says you need to get some sleep
tonight baby a little extra cup by my
friends my family my fans my colleagues
my community this kind of community that
shows up that comes here to hear me
inspire and amaze and wants to hear that
poem that ends with that fiery blaze but
shows up to find me having one of those
days when I stand on this stage trying
to guide someone home it can't seem to
believe the words of my own poem but you
do you see in my story your truth that
you were perfection in process that you
are rapture in route and I'll stare at
my reflection in this audience's eyes
and you stare back at your reflection
pupils provide and we shout aloud but to
ourselves with fire and try I don't know
what you think you see from your side
but you you must not be looking at me
because I am
oops
thank you all thank y'all I appreciation
thank you this episode is brought to you
by 99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design I recommend checking
out 99designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one York Times best seller I've
also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs.com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 99 dollar upgrade on your first
design so check it out 99 designs.com
forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by audible which I've
used for years I love audio books and I
have to to recommend right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite audio
book of all time and that is the
graveyard book by neil gaiman the only
audiobook I've wanted to immediately
listen to a second time as soon as I
finished it's amazing you will thank me
the graveyard book the second is
vagabonding Bhairav pots which had a
huge impact on my life and form the
basis for a lot of what became the
4-hour workweek so all you need to do to
get your free 30-day trial is go to
audible com forward slash Tim and you
can choose one of those two books the
graveyard book bag bonding or more than
180,000 audio programs so that could be
a book that could be a magazine that
could be a newspaper could be a class
it's that easy go to audible.com forward
slash Tim that's audible com forward
slash Tim and grab a book enjoy
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or go to for our blog com fo u
rho r baoji com where you'll find an
award-winning blog tons of audio and
video interview stories with people like
Warren Buffett and mike shinoda from
Lincoln Park the books plus much much
more follow him on twitter at
twitter.com slash t Ferris that's two
fer Riss or on facebook at facebook.com
slash tim ferriss till next time thanks
for listening